good morning Hank it's Tuesday January
3rd 2023 which means get this
vlogbrothers just turned 16.
vlogbrothers can drive like Hank I don't
want to alarm you but there are people
watching this video who were born after
vlogbrothers after all these years I
sometimes feel like making a
vlogbrothers video every Tuesday is a
normal or natural phenomenon but in fact
it is a gift newly given each week it is
a real gift to be able to make stuff
with my brother and to be able to make
stuff with a community I care about and
it is also a choice I choose each
Tuesday whether to make a video and
viewers in turn choose whether to watch
it and I do sometimes struggle to
remember that things I choose to do
routinely are still choices which is why
every year I write myself two letters
one looking back at the year that was
and one looking ahead to the year that
will be to try to understand the choices
that I'm making and be intentional about
them and usually in the look ahead
letters I set certain goals like this
year I'm gonna exercise size 150 minutes
per week or this year I'm gonna finish
the anthropocene reviewed book or
whatever and historically I have a
pretty good track record when it comes
to accomplishing these goals but over
the years Hank the vast majority of
these goals have had one thing in common
which is that they involve in some way
turning it up a notch write this book
start that YouTube channel make this
podcast produce that movie some form of
you know just take it up to 11 for a
year and often what I need in life is to
turn it up to push myself to build my
confidence whatever but sometimes Hank
sometimes you need to take it down a
notch and that's my only goal for 2023
just take it down a notch like last year
Hank there were several times where I
got mad at a stranger on the internet
and engaged in a debate with them about
like I don't know whether or not access
to life-saving medications is a human
right or a luxury and then I would be
like late to dinner with my family
because I was so busy yelling at a
stranger even though that didn't make my
life better or their life better nor did
it expand access to health care and what
I want to do in 2020 E3 is take it down
a notch by for example advocating for
Global Health Equity and better funding
for Health Care Systems without yelling
at first name bunch of numbers on the
internet like some of you may know that
many years ago I worked as a student
chaplain at a children's hospital and
after doing that work I got a temp job
at book list magazine just typing
numbers into a database and the first
like year that I worked there even
though I am a very anxious person I had
a reputation for being calm Under
Pressure because whatever was happening
at the magazine I would be like well but
it's it's just a magazine you know like
it's important I care about this job and
everything but like the Magazine's
probably going to come out it's come out
for 104 consecutive years and that's the
energy I want to bring into 2023 my work
is important but it's not that important
like you know what nobody thinks when
they walk into a library oh this place
is almost complete it just needs one
more John Green Book so yeah that's my
goal for 2023 am I getting short with
people I love take it down a notch am I
defining myself entirely by my work or
worrying that the way people see me is
more important than the way I am take it
down a notch am I panicked about a
deadline take it down a notch this is
not a hospital nobody's gonna die from
neglect if this week's vlogbrothers
video isn't as good as it might have
been it occurs to me belatedly that this
video might be putting pressure on
people who do work in hospitals which is
certainly not my intention
um thank you for that difficult work
that I bombed out of so dramatically
also I feel like if that young
whippersnapper me who's 16 years ago had
just made his first ever Vlog where this
video saw this one he would be like what
are you talking about like life is about
turning it up to 11 for as long as you
can but to that me I would just say be
careful what you ridicule my friend for
in time you will become it I grow old I
grow old I shall wear the bottoms of my
trousers rolled Hank I'll see you on
Friday unless you're busy on Friday in
which case that's all right man we're
taking it down a notch in 2023.